whoa what dog
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody its charlie we got a freak
out about new spider-man far from home
there's a new trailer that's coming
really soon to that I'll explain but
most of you probably remember when jake
gyllenhaal almost replaced Tobey Maguire
as spider-man on spider-man 2 so I'll
explain what's going on at this it's
just a fun teaser with a couple big
Easter eggs and then obviously a really
good look at the two new spider-man
suits in far from home we're doing a new
round of that IMAX ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
spider-man moment on the video the big
thing here Jake Gyllenhaal just joining
social media and confirming that he's
playing Mysterio but we knew that he was
playing the stereo for a long time
because we saw them filming scenes with
him in his full-on tech Quentin Beck
Mysterio looking costume but even if you
see it with your own eyes you
technically can't call it official until
Marvel makes the announcement and this
is their way of doing that in a just a
funny ha-ha moment like the way that Tom
Holland nowadays accidentally totally on
purpose
spoils stuff because it's all part of
their marketing plan the reason why
they're dropping a trailer this weekend
and why Jake Gyllenhaal is dropping all
these teasers and Tom Holland is being
really funny in the background too is
because CC XP Brasil Comic Con is
happening in studios take a whole bunch
of footage because it's the last big
convention of the year Jake Gyllenhaal
himself is making a joke about the time
that he almost became spider-man during
the Tobey Maguire era that's what that
caption guys I just realized I'm not
playing spider-man is all about if
you're really young and you weren't
around for that or if you don't remember
what happened is is when they were
filming spider-man 2 Tobey Maguire hurt
his back really bad and couldn't
continue filming so Sony was getting
ready to replace him as spider-man with
Jake Gyllenhaal
they had him all ready to go Tobey
Maguire marshaled every person in
Hollywood that he could to help him beg
for his job back in spider-man and Sony
and the producers reinstated him so we
got Tobey Maguire spider-man 2 in
spider-man 3 but for a really brief
period Jake Gyllenhaal was almost
spider-man so when you see those Jake
Gyllenhaal Photoshop jobs of him as
spider-man that's what that's all about
the comic book that he's reading is
amazing spider-man number 311 the return
of a man called Mysterio in the one
that's framed behind him and the wall is
amazing spider-man
66 the madness of Mysterio both of them
are references to some of the
inspiration for the story of the movie
just like a little bit of the story of
the movie and a little bit of the
character confirming him as the Quentin
Beck Mysterio the one that he's reading
here is actually part of a larger Marvel
Inferno arc it's a big x-men crossover
from the late 80s the x-men were huge
during that period so obviously a lot of
the crossovers were centered around them
but in this issue Mysterio is trying to
fundamentally break
spider-man psyche by creating illusions
to make him think that he's responsible
for the death of an innocent person
spider-man figures out that all the
evidence from the crime scene wasn't
real it was an illusion making him think
of Mysterio so he tracks him down but
their big final battle in the issue
takes place on the set of a sci-fi
action movie so spider-man's big
solution for taking him down is to just
cut off the power supply that Mysterio
is using to power all of this technology
the real meta thing here that I'm hoping
that they go for a bit of an easter egg
is because spider-man is such a pop
culture movie reference person in the
MCU is is because that battle takes
place on the set of a sci-fi action
movie so wouldn't it be funny if we're
watching Tom Holland in a movie fight
Mysterio on the set of a movie but I
don't know if they would go for an
Easter Egg that deep this is just a
little speculation but the issue on the
wall behind him amazing spider-man 66 is
a direct reference to a scene that we
know is happening in the movie remember
all the behind the scenes footage we saw
of spider-man fighting Mysterio on the
carousel set when they were traveling
through Europe this is meant to be
Prague Czech Republic in the movie but
they filmed it somewhere else in real
life but in amazing spider-man 66
Mysterio goes on live television to
challenge spider-man to a battle it
takes place at a carnival and the other
cool Easter egg about Mysterio you guys
have probably realized is that in real
life Mysterio is following the vulture
as the main villain of a big spider-man
sequel but in the comics Marvel actually
retcon Mysterio's first appearance so an
amazing spider-man number 2 the first
appearance of the vulture spider-man
battles him but in the same issue
there's a group of aliens that Marvel
later retconned to say that it was
Mysterio using his technology to
disguise himself so Mysterio essentially
follows the vulture as the next big
villain even the
in reality he didn't debut till a little
bit later in the comics the video the
suit shoots gives you a much better look
at them up close so we have the shield
stealth suit that Nick Fury probably
gives him then we have the upgraded
stark tech suit made to look like the
original Steve Ditko black and red suit
there's still a lot of unanswered
questions about what's going on with
these because all the footage we've seen
of them doesn't involve any real special
effects or CG or anything like that like
what other tech is embedded in this
shield armor because this really does
look like it's inspired by the Spider
Man noir costume but it's made to look
like a stealth armor suit with like a
giant chest plate like it's designed
more like a tactical suit that he would
wear into battle as opposed to his
normal spider-man suit which is a little
more lightweight the reason why I say
this is probably a shield suit is
because it has a shield emblem on it and
we know that he's wearing it in the
fight at the big carousel that I was
just talking about and Nick Fury shows
up while he's traveling around Europe we
seen him in the canals here so he shows
up and probably helps spider-man with
some new gear to fight Mysterio and the
other sinister people that he's working
with the most practical theory that I've
seen about why he needs this special
armor stealth suit is because he's
traveling through Europe with all of his
classmates it if spider-man in his
traditional stark tech suit showed up
everywhere that Peter Parker did anybody
with a cellphone and a social media
account would eventually find out his
secret identity pretty easy to guess
that MJ also figures out a secret
identity separately but we don't know
when that's going to happen during the
movie but just a quick timeline
explainer the movie itself is supposed
to pick up after the events of Avengers
for like minutes after Avengers 4 they
didn't say anything about any time jumps
or anything like that so we'll find out
about that pretty soon the movie is not
supposed to be a prequel but there's
still a whole lot of questions we have
about how Avengers fix the timeline in a
way that brings everyone back from being
dusted without a lot of the regular
people remembering that they died but I
do think that it's really important for
his character development that
spider-man remember the snap sure
remembering that you died for a little
while is so great for his inner turmoil
they can mind that for the next couple
of movies they did that with Iron Man
after the first Avengers movie like the
trauma of almost dying when he was in
outer space sending the nuke through the
portal they didn't pay that off to Iron
Man 3 but think about Spider Man getting
a similar
version of that but the new rumor right
now is that the Avengers four trailer is
supposed to drop Friday morning in the
spider-man far from home trailer will
drop Saturday morning so whenever it
drops I will totally make videos for it
no worries
there's also supposed to be some
Avengers related stuff happening
tomorrow but I don't know what that's
going to be if it's cool I will totally
make a video for it congratulations
Saul gee you're the giveaway winner from
my last big Marvel video please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here to re-watch
the Captain Marvel trailer and click
here for my non-spoilery spider-man into
the spider verse review thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]